うんこ💩
なんかあれですよね
なんか手にこうやって置いて…拷問みたいですけど
てか合成が雑だなぁ…
ウソ発見器の上に手を置いて
質問されます→それが嘘だったら
こんな髪の毛立つ～！？髪の毛こんなになる！？
さすがにここまではなんないでしょう。多分盛ってますね。
イメージではこれぐらいなんかビリビリってするらしいでございます。
開けてみましょう！
ドンキで売ってるんですけど、このドンキで買えるもので
嘘を見抜けるようだったら、世の中の嘘を全部暴いていきたいレベルなんですけど。
うわ～なんかそれなりにそれっぽい。
これがウソ発見器です。
うわっ！！！あ、吸盤が付いてるんだ。
一回ちょっとやってみましょうか。
うわっ！びっくりした。
固定するの嫌やなぁ～
スタートボタン押します！
音楽が鳴り終わったら準備完了らしいです。
質問して、「はい」か「いいえ」を答えてもらってください。
自分で自分に質問します。
ピコーン◎(電子音)
あれー？俺カレーライス食ってねぇぞ～？
やっぱ自分で自分に質問したからよくないんだな
誰かから質問されないと
正常な判断が出来ないのかもしれません。
自分でやってるとホントになっちゃうんで。
ピコーン◎(電子音)
ん？お金嫌いってことかー！！！！
正しいな～俺。しっかりできてんなぁ！
これで僕がお金が好きじゃないってことが証明…いや違うっ！
これホントに正しいかどうかっていうのは分かんないんですよね。
あと！！！！今回ウソ発見器を沢山準備しました！
これによって…これは！正しかったんですけども
他のウソ発見器が正しいかどうかっていうのは分からないので
そしたら嘘っぱちでやってるかもしれないし、ホントに正しいかもしれない
このウソ発見器がホントにちゃんとしてるかどうかを
色んなウソ発見器を使って確かめていこうと思います！
ではいこう！
というわけでまず、ウソ発見器を開けていきましょう！
よし！
え？今…なんで？
というわけで、合計１０個の！ウソ発見器を準備しました！
今回どう、検証していくかといいますと、
今から一つの質問をしてもらいます。
その質問に僕が答えます。それが嘘だったら電撃が流れるんですよ。
同じ質問を１０回繰り返して、１個ずつやっていって
これがホントに正確なウソ発見器だったら
１０回ともちゃんと電流が流れる
という感じの分かりやすい検証になっております。
では、やっていきましょう！
ﾋﾟｯ(ウソ発見器)
えっ！？
え？？
ﾋﾟｯ(ウソ発見器)
えっ！？
ではいきます！まず１個目！
いだあああああああああああい！！！！！
好きなのにいいいいいいいい！！！
好きなのにぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃ好きなのにぃ……………(涙
まぁウソってことですね。
はじめはヒカキンが嫌いなのか？
もはや多数決
いいえ
イタッ